[Musique]
mobilisation des soignants en europe
pour plus d'égalité dans les hôpitaux en
france dans la capitale plusieurs
centaines ont dénoncé le manque de
moyens
après un rassemblement devant l'hôpital
de la pitié salpêtrière sont arrivés à
l'hôtel de ville où ils ont finalement
été dispersés à 18h la transition au
mali au coeur d'un sommet extraordinaire
des chefs d'état ouest africains demain
la nomination la situation est
incertaine après la nomination du
colonel à 6 me go ita comme président de
la transition les intentions du nouvel
homme fort du pays inquiète la
communauté internationale après ces deux
derniers coups d'état en colombie le
bilan des nouvelles manifestations
antigouvernementales s'alourdit au moins
dix morts la nuit dernière à cali dans
le sud-ouest de bogota face à la colère
sociale qui gronde depuis un mois le
président yves adoue quai a ordonné hier
le déploiement de l'armée dans les rues
de la troisième ville du pays épicentre
de la contestation
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à toutes et à toutes et
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez sur rt
france mouvement de contestation des
soignants dans une dizaine de pays
européens aujourd'hui pour défendre un
service de santé égalitaire pour tous en
france à paris des centaines de
soignants étaient dans la rue pour
dénoncer le manque de moyens matériels
et humains dans les hôpitaux publics
malgré la récente revalorisation des
salaires accordées par le gouvernement
pour le personnel de santé ce n'est pas
suffisant selon eux ils ne sont plus en
mesure de prendre en charge correctement
les patients d'autres manifestations ont
également eu lieu à marseille rennes
bruxelles milan ou encore à barcelone à
paris le cortège est parti de l'hôpital
de la pitié salpêtrière pour rejoindre
l'hôtel de ville avant d'être dispersés
par les forces de l'ordre je vous
propose d'écouter quelques manifestants
chaque année nous en france on a des
économies qui sont faites pour l'hôpital
public d'un milliard à chaque fois on a
un budget qui est deux fois moins
important que les besoins donc à chaque
fois on fait des économies et ça malgré
la crise on a on va continuer dans le
même système
on peut pas continuer comme ça on a vu
que c'est important d'avoir un certain
système de santé fort solidaire ça c'est
super important
on est tous victimes des mêmes choses et
on dénonce tous les mêmes choses une
santé qui n'est plus à la hauteur des
besoins de la population dans son
capacitaire dans le nombre de lits dans
les hôpitaux par exemple pour accueillir
les patients dans les effectifs de nos
collègues dans les services pour prendre
en charge le patient est dans la
reconnaissance de nos métiers qui à
l'évidence on sous-estimé sous payés par
rapport à des métiers équivalent dans
d'autres dans d'autres secteurs de
l'économie
on sort un peu dedans
on avait complètement la tête dans le
guidon et on a l'impression que ce qui
s'est passé et les difficultés qu'on a
rencontrée c'est en grande partie parce
qu'on n'avait pas été écoutés jusque là
alors que ça faisait des années qu'on
était dans la rue qu'on me disait que
l'hôpital y pouvait pas tenir avec la
moindre tension supplémentaire parce
qu'on était déjà toujours sous tension
malgré ça il ya rien qui bouge vraiment
que le soi-disant choc d'attractivité ça
change rien parce que c'est pas en
enfilant 60 balles de plus aux
infirmières qu'on arrivera à recruter
davantage et du coup tout le monde est à
bout on en a marre un concert pas comme
les autres a débuté à 18 heures avec le
groupe hors d'eau chine qui vous devant
5000 personnes pour un spectacle qui
doit faire office de test il a lieu à
l'accord arena de paris le protocole
pour les participants il y est stricte
ils ont passé un test de dépistage du
coc vite 19 avant le concert dans la
salle ils doivent porter un masque
il s'agit de voir si ce genre
d'événement entraîne des contaminations
car les spectateurs seront testés
ensuite pour voir s'ils sont toujours
négatifs aux convives 19 à barcelone ce
type de test a déjà été réalisé sans
aucune contamination en décembre dernier
mais dans la revue britannique the
lancet tu des chercheurs ont émis des
doutes sur la valeur du résultat car les
devants les salles de concerts des lieux
d'expériences scientifiques grandeur
nature testées négatives au co vide
avant le spectacle 500 personnes
s'étaient réunies sans distanciation
sociale lors du premier concert tests
européens à barcelone en décembre
dernier huit jours plus tard
aucun cas positif n'avait été relevée un
résultat rassurant mais d'après hollande
il n'était pas vraiment représentatif
notre étude apporte deux premières
données montrant que des événements
musicaux en intérieur peuvent se tenir
sans augmenter le risque de transmission
du sarm skov 2 lorsque des mesures de
précautions sont prises
mais ne signifie pas nécessairement que
tous les grands rassemblements soient
sûrs pour les chercheurs lors de ce
concert test la circulation du virus
était relativement faible en espagne
autres facteurs pouvant expliquer
l'absence de contamination les
conditions strictes imposées lors de ce
test
en plus d'être confirmée négatif avant
l'événement les spectateurs devaient
porter un masque ffp2 côté sécurité des
agents étaient chargés d'éviter les
mouvements de foule
une organisation coûteuse et compliquée
encadré autre test
autres résultats à liverpool ou
plusieurs événements ont réuni jusqu'à
treize mille personnes négatives au
coville 10,9 début mai après le concert
11 personnes et est ressortie positive
mais le port du masque n'était cette
fois pas obligatoire un résultat
toutefois peu significatif plus de la
moitié des participants n'ont pas
communiqué les résultats de leurs tests
pcr autre titre de cette édition la
réunion extraordinaire des chefs d'état
ouest africains sur la situation au mali
demain la cour constitutionnelle a
déclaré hier le colonel assis meego ita
président de la transition malgré ses
deux coups de force militaire dont le
dernier s'est déroulé lundi
beaucoup de questions se posent
désormais sur la suite du processus d'un
retour à un pouvoir civil les précisions
de grégoire douce et nouveau jeu de
chaises musicales au mali neuf mois
après le coup d'état de la junte
militaire colonel est jusqu'ici vice
président de la transition
ah si meego ita partie prenante du
premier putsch s'empare du pouvoir à la
suite d'un nouveau coup de force
quelques jours plus tôt il écartait le
président bah ndo et le premier ministre
moctar ouane les accusant de ne pas
l'avoir consulté à propos de la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
il fallait choisir entre la stabilité et
mallet et les cra où nous avons su
allier la stabilité
il fallait ça j'ai rappelé jason et la
cohésion au sein des forces de défense
et de sécurité
vous avez sauvé la fusion des progrès
pensent les security
le nouvel homme fort du mali pourrait
rebattre les cartes de la situation au
sahel en proie au djihadisme depuis de
nombreuses années la france engagée
militairement dans la région depuis 2013
et les états unis qui soutiennent
matériellement l'opération barkan ont
d'ores et déjà menacé de mettre en place
des sanctions contre bamako
de leur côté les soutiens d'aci meego
ita ont défilé dans les rues de la
capitale malienne
une partie d'entre eux réclament l'arrêt
de l'intervention française et préférait
un engagement russe une volonté résonne
parmi les manifestants celle de régler
entre maliens la crise politique que
traverse le pays
[Musique]
des classes ont divisé les avoir assez
des civils qui s'affolent et partis
politiques
mais ça soit la jeunesse du week-end au
lycée aujourd'hui les scènes croquées
unis c'est l'armée pour l'eau
la survie après le putsch l'année passée
la transition initiée par la junte avait
pour objectif annoncé de ramener des
civils à la tête du pays à l'horizon
pour ali ton kara directeur du centre
des études sécuritaires et stratégiques
au sahel colonel assimile go ita a
réussi à séduire une partie de l'armée
par son discours en quatre mois ce qui
reste quand même observable la mrc
montre solidaire où il a vite à quand on
interrogeait sa trajectoire militaire on
comprend aisément le pot mois d'une
telle rigueur de manifester
les éléments de défense sécurité
vis-à-vis de la personne de brita est un
peu long quand même c'était un homme de
terrain
beaucoup d'états dernier lesquels on dit
et surtout légalement est parvenu à
faire adhérer un nombre important de ses
supérieurs qui se trouvait également le
tout sur des quatre sensible c'est la
fédé lui alpha oméga vis-à-vis d'une
partie de l'armée
la visite des manuels maquereau en
afrique du sud s'est achevée aujourd'hui
le chef de l'état en opération séduction
lors de sa tournée qui l'a donc mené au
moins d'appuis à pretoria hier il s'est
prononcée pour la levée des contraintes
sur la propriété intellectuelle des
vaccins une déclaration alors que la
vaccination tourne au ralenti sur le
continent quant à mme auclair
2 % c'est la proportion de personnes
vaccinées sur le continent africain
un taux dérisoire qui illustrent l'échec
jusqu'ici de la vaccination en afrique
le président rwandais paul kagamé s'en
est vivement pris à la lenteur de la
vaccination sur le continent juste après
la visite des manuels maquereau au
rwanda il reste très inefficace très
scandaleusement inefficace l'afrique a
besoin de vaccins comme tout le monde
cela ne fait aucun doute
on ne peut pas avoir des vaccins pour
certains et pas pour d'autres
emmanuel macron qui s'est ensuite rendu
en afrique du sud s'est prononcée pour
la levée temporaire des brevets des
vaccins anti coville 19 lors de son
discours ce samedi il a insisté sur la
nécessaire hausse drastique du rythme de
vaccination en afrique
objectif 40 % de vacciner d'ici la fin
de l'année puis 60% d'ici mi 2011 22 le
président français lancés dans une
véritable opération séduction en terre
africaine
ces deux déplacements sont l'une de ses
rares sorties hors europe depuis un an
ont démis oblige à pretoria emmanuel
macron a dit vouloir développer un
partenariat durable avec comme point de
départ le sommet afrique-france prévues
à montpellier en octobre prochain
ce partenariat pour moi est extrêmement
important et vient compléter tout ce qui
est fait sur le plan institutionnel
gouvernementale par des acteurs
installés
parce qu'il va aider aussi à changer les
regards et les esprits et pour nous
françaises et français c'est très
important parce que je l'espère aussi
des millions de jeunes gens qui ont une
histoire avec l'afrique par leur famille
par des générations qui viennent de
première génération du continent
africain on va enfin leur dire on a
quelque chose à bâtir en commun va pas
leur dire c'est un problème et vous
devez vous intégrez mardi vous êtes une
chance pour la france
et vous allez nous aider à développer
cette histoire commune un objectif déjà
annoncé au début
de son quinquennat aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron tentent de réinventer les
relations entre la france et l'afrique à
travers ce partenariat
il espère tisser des liens stratégiques
avec les puissances économiques
africaines qui émerge chose que ses
prédécesseurs n'ont jamais réussi à
faire en dehors de la traditionnelle
sphère d'influencé française actualité
en amérique du sud avec ces nouvelles
violences la nuit dernière en colombie
un mois après le début des
manifestations antigouvernementales au
moins dix personnes sont mortes vendredi
à cali à l'origine de la contestation
un projet de réforme fiscale qui a
finalement été abandonnée par le
président conservateur ivan bouquet face
aux manifestations ce dernier a durci le
ton il a envoyé l'armée à qu'allié
l'épicentre du mouvement médias ce qui
fit une colère sociale qui perdure et un
bilan humain qui s'alourdit
face à cette situation le président ivan
bouquet a ordonné le déploiement de
l'armée dans les rues
je veux qu'il soit absolument clair qu'
à partir de ce soir le déploiement
maximal de l'assistance militaire à la
police nationale commence dans la ville
de cali et dans le département de valle
del cauca
ce déploiement va presque tripler notre
capacité en moins de 24 heures dans tout
l'état en assurant également une
assistance au point critique où nous
avons assisté à des actes de vandalisme
de violence et de terrorisme urbain de
faible intensité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des violences qui interviennent tout
juste un mois après le début des
manifestations lancées à la base contre
un projet de réforme fiscale du
gouvernement
malgré le retrait rapide de ce projet
par ivan doké la mobilisation s'est
poursuivie
les manifestants dénoncent désormais la
violence des forces de l'ordre et la
corruption du gouvernement
[Musique]
nous ne nous résignons toujours pas à
devoir attendre un changement parce que
beaucoup de personnes sont mortes durant
les marches
nous voulons travailler dans la dignité
et que le gouvernement nous donne des
garanties à nous ainsi qu'aux jeunes
nous n'allons pas nous lasser de la
grève nationale parce que nous
continuons le combat parce que je suis
là pour mes élèves pour offrir un
meilleur avenir pour eux et ma fille
nous ne sommes plus invisible pour
l'état le mouvement contestataire sans
précédent en colombie bloque une partie
des activités du pays et provoque des
pénuries
conséquence certains habitants sont
exaspérés le scénario se répète presque
chaque jour des rassemblements dans le
calme la journée qui tourne à l'émeute
une fois la nuit tombée
[Musique]
je vienne quel fou qui hier secrétaire
national du parti de gauche et
spécialiste de l'amérique du sud pointe
la responsabilité du pouvoir colombien
dans ces événements faut comprendre que
ces manifestations qui ont lieu depuis
un mois sur la poursuite du mouvement
social qui a eu fin 2019 début 2020 et
qui a dû s'arrêter pour cause de
qu'ovide puisqu'aujourd'hui la situation
en colombie
plus que simplement cette réforme
fiscale c'est un mal être qui est
profond et qui existent dans la société
et pour lesquels à la fois par les
résultats électoraux et par plusieurs
mouvement social on voit qu'il ya de la
contestation voit que le modèle
colombien ne satisfait plus l'ensemble
de la population la majorité de la
population et principalement les jeunes
donc effectivement il était un précédent
qui sont les manifestations 2019
c'est pour ça que ces manifestations et
c'est quelque chose que exemple j'ai un
peu vu sur votre sujet avec j'ai pu
aussi - voire dans d'autres journaux on
doit les prendre dans un ensemble c'est
pas juste une exception il ya eu un
phénomène de violence qui a duré un mois
à cette période de deux mètres de mils
21 ans et c'est un système d'ensemble
c'est quelque chose que d'avoir de
manière beaucoup plus structurelle c'est
un mal-être existe au sein de la société
et pour beaucoup de colombiens et
colombiennes et ça depuis depuis mal
depuis malheureusement des années et
direction le brésil où des milliers de
manifestants sont attendus ce soir dans
plusieurs villes du pays le mot d'ordre
dénoncer la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par le président jacques bolle
sonar ou les résultats de l enquête
parlementaire accable le gouvernement au
brésil environ 460 mille personnes sont
mortes du comique 19
hervé théry géographe et professeur à
l'université de sao paulo revient sur la
part de responsabilité du président jean
paul sarault et de son gouvernement dans
cette gestion de la crise sanitaire
maintenant il ya eu des enquêtes qui
sont faites par les sénateurs à part le
il parlait les parlementaires qui ont
convoqué des ministres et les ministres
se contredisent à tout moment et donc
vraiment maintenant on assez bien
établie nulle part une rien organisé
pour lutter contre et même on sait
maintenant qu'ils ont laissé plusieurs
propositions des fabricants de vaccins
sans réagir
et donc ils ont directement la
responsabilité de ne pas avoir acheté
des vaccins
organiser même d'avoir assez souvent
saboter les actions des états 27 et à
vous constituer le brésil le
gouvernement fédéral ne les a pas aidés
d amen bloqués dans le reste de
l'actualité internationale en bref et en
images funérailles la nuit dernière au
sud de naplouse en cisjordanie occupée
celle d'un palestinien tué hier par des
tirs de soldats israéliens lors
d'affrontements les tensions restent
fortes au proche-orient plus d'une
semaine après le cessez le feu conclu
entre israël et le hamas
le récent conflit armé entre les deux
parties a fait plus de 260 morts en onze
jours essentiellement dans la bande de
gaza manifestations entier avortements
en croatie ils étaient des milliers à
défiler dans les rues de zagreb un
rassemblement à la veille d'élections
locales où l'un des favoris est un
défenseur du droit à l'avortement pour
rappel avortement illégal jusqu'à la
dixième semaine de grossesse en croatie
mais le sujet divise la société
dans un pays où 90% de la population est
catholique
la croatie qui va acheter douze rafale à
la france zagreb se dote de l'avion de
chasse français après new delhi athènes
et le caire récemment
problème la mise en place de prêts en
grande partie garanti par paris
notamment dans le cadre du contrat passé
avec l'egypte le contribuable français
pourrait donc mettre la main à la poche
les précisions avec françois-xavier
l'envers c'est une belle revanche pour
ce fleuron de l'aéronautique française
de défense
entré en service en 2004 le rafale a dû
patienter plus de dix ans avant de se
vendre hors de france
un parcours laborieux marqué par des
échecs lors d'appels d'offres en corée
du sud aux pays bas au maroc aux émirats
ou encore au brésil
le chasseur de dassault aviation traîne
alors une réputation d'appareils
invendables mais peu à peu son image
s'améliore tandis qu'il enchaîne les
missions à partir de 2007 en afghanistan
puis en libye au sahel et enfin en irak
et en syrie
autant d'opérations où son utilisation
s'avère décisive pour l'armée française
les premiers succès à l'export finissent
par arriver en 2015 l'egypte et le qatar
commandes à eux deux une cinquantaine
d'appareils
et puis en 2016 c'est un méga contrat
qui est signé avec l'inde
montant estimé à 9,4 milliards de
dollars
un succès qui se poursuit donc cette
année depuis janvier la grèce l'egypte
et donc la croatie on passer de
nouvelles commandes à ce jour au total
156 rafales ont été vendus à l'étranger
une réussite dont se félicite la
ministre des armées françaises le fait
qu'un pays européens choisissent l'offre
d'un autre pays européen est un signe
fort qui dépasse le symbole après
plusieurs succès dans le cadre de
procédure de gré à gré l'avion français
s'impose ainsi pour la première fois
dans le cadre d'un processus compétitif
cette dynamique confirment l'excellence
de l'offre française dans les domaines
technologiques de pointe
si le succès du rafale s'explique par sa
fiabilité
l'appareil profite aussi des
défaillances de son principal concurrent
le f-35 américains plus cher décrit
comme difficile à manoeuvrer
et qui subit de nombreuses avaries
techniques l'avion de dassault bénéficie
aussi d'une plus grande implication du
gouvernement français depuis le
quinquennat de françois hollande
mais ce soutien de paris comporte aussi
des zones d'ombré notamment dans le
cadre du contrat passé fin avril avec
l'egypte pour l'achat de 30 rafale une
vente rendue possible par un prêt de dix
ans en grande partie garanti par l'état
français
selon le site d'investigation disclose
c'est donc le contribuable français qui
pourrait payer l'ardoisé si l'egypte ne
respectait pas ses engagements
surendetté l'état égyptien a en effet
obtenu un prêt garanti par la france à
hauteur de 85% sur dix ans
si l'egypte n'arrivent pas à rembourser
c'est donc le contribuable français qui
devra effacer l'ardoisé de 3,4 milliards
d'euros laissés par le caire sans
compter les intérêts cette polémique ne
devrait pas empêcher l'année 2021 d'être
particulièrement faste pour le rafale et
son constructeur dassault aviation le
rafale est en compétition en suisse et
en finlande pour remporter des appels
d'offres il intéresse également les
émirats arabes unis sur les ventes
successives de rafale et les intérêts
géopolitiques qui vont avec écoutez
l'analyse de sébastien nadeau il est
député du groupe parlementaire liberté
territoire également membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères
c'est un succès diplomatique ce dont on
vient de parler
en revanche sur la question commerciale
ça reste avec bien des interrogations et
vous l'avez relevé juste avant on vend
des rafales à l'egypte mais on ne sait
pas à quel moment et si et quel montant
va récupérer la même question se pose
avec la croatie plus d'un milliard
d'euros à ce moment de crise la
questionne sur la réalité d'un retour
financier
la géopolitique la diplomatie c'est un
jeu de dominos quant à la manière dont
la france
influence l'egypte à travers des ventes
de rafale
si vous me posez cette question
j'aimerais bien qu'elle influence
l'egypte sur la question des droits de
l'homme et pour l'instant force est de
constater que
de ce côté là le président emmanuel
macro est en échec
joe biden souffle le chaud et le froid
après avoir conclu un accord pour
prolonger le traité sur la limitation de
l'arsenal nucléaire avec la russie le
président américain renonce à réintégrer
le traité ciel ouvert sapé par les
violations de la russie selon la maison
blanche
une attitude qui une fois de plus
pourraient compromettre l'apaisement des
relations entre washington et moscou
plus de précision avec akamai a soufflé
un changement de cap qui pourrait
exacerber les tensions américano russes
après être revenu dans plusieurs accords
internationaux pour rompre avec la
politique à courte vue de son
prédécesseur joe biden a annoncé qu'il
ne reviendrait pas dans le traité de
surveillance militaire ciel ouvert un
traité que les états unis avaient quitté
en novembre 2020
trump estimant à l'époque que la russie
ne respectait pas les termes du traité
un argument est désormais repris par
l'administration byden les états unis
regrettent que le traité ciel ouvert est
été sapée par les violations de la
russie en concluant son réexamen du
traité les états unis n'entendent donc
pas chercher à le rejoindre en raison du
fait que la russie n'a pris aucune
mesure pour le respecter à nouveau le
comportement de la russie notamment sur
ses récentes actions concernant
l'ukraine n'est pas celui d'un
partenaire déterminé à rebâtir la
confiance
le 19 mai dernier les députés de la
douma ont également voté le retrait du
traité
tout en espérant une solution
constructive des états unis le vice
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
déplore aujourd'hui la décision de joe
biden les états unis ont commis une
énième erreur politique et porté un
nouveau coup au système de sécurité en
europe
nous leur avons donné une bonne occasion
mais ils n'en ont pas profité
entrée en vigueur en janvier 2002 le
traité ciel ouvert repose sur le concept
d'observation aérienne mutuelle les pays
sont autorisés à survoler les bases
militaires des états membres pour
observer leurs activités lorsqu'il était
candidat à la maison blanche
joe biden estimé que le retrait des
états unis étaient néfastes pour les
relations entre l'occident et la russie
il opter à l'époque pour une résolution
des conflits sans tourner le dos aux
textes
aujourd'hui le président américain
rétropédale mais affirme malgré tout
vouloir trouver un terrain d'entente
avec le kremlin en termes de sécurité
internationale à quelques semaines d'une
rencontre avec vladimir poutine à genève
la décision de joe biden pourrait être
l'un des nombreux sujets épineux abordés
entre les deux chefs d'état est tout de
suite heurtées sur le web une sélection
d'articles à retrouver sur notre site
rt france pointé vers manuel valls
parodié par an médias catalans après sa
démission au poste de conseiller
municipal à barcelone une vidéo devenue
virale qui ne plaît pas à l'ancien
premier ministre
elle montre qu'il ne sera pas du tout
regretté il a qualifié la chaîne de
télévision espagnole et l'émission dans
laquelle la parodie a été diffusée de
véritable machine de propagande visant à
le discréditer
présentatrice de la bbc lyse à chaud est
décédé à 44 ans quelques jours après sa
première injection au vaccin astrazeneca
la famille de la victime a expliqué
qu'elle a développé de graves maux de
tête une semaine après avoir été
vaccinée
[Musique]
critiqué pour avoir donné une interview
à l'hebdomadaire conservateur valeurs
actuelles qui a fait sa une sur je cite
le délire transgenres gabriela talent
assume le porte parole du gouvernement
affirme avoir toujours défendu ses
convictions
peu importe sur quels médias il a
toutefois déclaré que la première page
du magazine l'a heurté voilà pour ce
journal merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
prochain point sur l'actualité dans ton
trentaine de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
en féminines ici des commis tous les
deux à trois jours en france
actuellement
pourquoi il joue ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent